what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
[Music]
friends
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
unwaxed podcast
with your most crazy and cringy but
also favorite sisters sophia and sistine
sloane you had to add the crazy and the
cringe in there i feel like the last
episode there's things i did that were
kind of cringe or
what did you do smash my boobs against a
window to your boyfriend or
ex-boyfriend yes yes that's story time
that was a story time a lot of people
liked that story time
um you know i do it for the listeners i
was a little bit humiliated
to rehash that whole thing you know what
i'm fine
times though like all about you a lot of
them about me
done too so a lot of the two are about
you well i told you to bring in one
and it ended up having to be about me i
guess
i was involved you know what the
problems were involved
your tits were involved my tits were
there to stay
but i think it's because i do a lot of
things that are accident prone
like i put myself into situations where
it ends up being the most embarrassing
thing ever
yeah a lot of times but i think i do it
too i just i just walk it off cooler
like you yeah for example you'll fall
and you'll stay on the ground
or i'll follow and it'll go into like a
doggy you know and i'm like
you go into a world you can drop it and
act like i did it on purpose
anyway you guys this is a very exciting
moment for me
because sophia decided to flee to la
and leave me for an entire week i did
and
i don't think you realize how lonely
i've been
well okay you know rape rewind i
facetimed you yesterday and i asked
have you been like are you do you miss
me and you're like no
well i'm just trying to be okay with it
and i was like should i just stay
another week
look here's the thing this is why it's
exciting because
i actually have so much to update you on
and so we're gonna do it
on the podcast because we talk every day
but there are so many things that happen
that you don't even know i know we wrote
out everything and she told me to avoid
the weekly update so um i have so you're
getting it in
tell that i haven't gone yet so okay
what was going on in palm
beach that i don't know about it aside
from eating alone
i just want you to understand like how
sad it is you have scarlet l.a
no i didn't she came later whatever i'd
have her dogs
mom and jen and sly going out having a
great time
i'm eating alone every night i'm working
out
alone every day do you understand that
i've been watching
because you know i love trish payatis
like i love trisha paytas
bangs is it mukbang it's mukbang mukbang
you know i'm really not in the trends so
i have no idea i think that's my thing
i got to a level of loneliness where i
actually would eat
my dinner with her on my computer screen
eating her dinner
oh that's it and we would eat together
that's really what seriously
i know but wait really yeah assistant
why
you could have facetimed me and i would
have had like maybe later or earlier
dinner
well that you love you had to see your
friends and do your thing
and that's a lie i love loneliness okay
yeah all right
anyway trisha if you want to um yo
eat with her in real life she would
actually have a freak out i actually
love her i've been watching her for
years but lately i've been on a binge
she's phenomenal you guys um trish like
fish on tick tock
like i love trish fiera's big stand stan
um okay another new thing that happened
that i realized about myself
i have a new phobia sophia another one
yes which one is this it's called the
lassophobia
philosophia
let me get the exact way to pronounce it
i guarantee it's not called falassal
philosophia oh gosh how did you get this
phobia or explain what it is
just listen to it
philosophy okay so you kind of said it
right yeah okay
so what is it it is a fear of the ocean
so what so i found i figured out that i
had no no i figured out that i had this
on tick tock
tick tock made me realize i had this new
phobia it's more not the fear of the
ocean but
the fear of what's below the surface
that you can't see
so dark blue waters so literally just
dangling your feet
in the water off of a ledge that
not knowing that something could come up
and grab you
do you think this has anything to do
with the fact that you shot a shark
movie
no are you sure like this look
okay that sistine that does not even
she's showing a photo
of i don't even know what that is it
looks like a
giant giant fish with trillions of teeth
like you see this dude from fine look
look at this look wouldn't you be scared
this one has what are you showing now
sistina she's showing the fish from
finding nemo
that is really scary in the teeth okay
okay i understand that
because just the fear of being pulled
down by i think it's the theory of the
unknown of what's below you okay i get
that
you have a clown fear so don't talk i
have such a clown fear
i hate clowns hate clowns circus away i
went when i was younger
i started crying you know what my dad
used to do to us when we were younger
sophie and i used to share a room maybe
this is why i'm so attached to you
we didn't have to share a room growing
up but we and scarlett uh wanted to be
part of this too so we had two beds in
our room
yeah and scarlett even brought in an air
mattress to sleep
below us oh and then we also had three
dogs so we had three dogs and three
girls in one room
and uh my dad every night if for some
reason when we were growing up he bought
these
really scary but actually beautiful
porcelain dolls from russia like
gorgeous faces you know when you lay
them down and the eyes closed and then
yeah they're really honestly works of
art and that's why he got them we
thought that
as little girls we would like it but
it's looks like the [ __ ] from annabelle
no it wasn't truly terrible i hated them
do you remember i feel like this i don't
understand why people fear sort of
started don't you remember
right when he was putting us to bed real
cozy tucked in
he'd get the doll and put it out into
the doorway and be like
girls and then yeah he's such a
jerk sometimes but then he put it in our
bed he put it in our bed when we were
sleeping we just
turn over and then there's like this
scary ass awesome staring at me one time
you put it he put it at the feet of my
bed
so i felt something when i moved at
night and i opened the cover that it was
a [ __ ] day
and there was also my fear from clowns
all system from the story that he told
us about the clown
that was true i know guys there's a
story i
can't i don't really want bringing it
back gives me kind of nightmares but
in short there was this clown in a
neighborhood
that used to always just be the the
clown on the street
i'm sorry i don't know why no one
thought that was a wrestler in the first
place a street clown
um but this guy ended up luring children
into his basement
and no it's a true story killing them
yeah he murdered multiple
kids boy i think it was young boys boys
so yes um when my dad told me that when
i was younger
it traumatized me and so i thought all
clowns did that
i also dressed as a clown every year for
hollywood yeah and then he just was a
clown for halloween and
i never talked to him so from that
phobia
yeah so you're scared of the ocean
scared of being pulled down
and other news um i always feel like
weird things happen to me in public
restrooms
uh yeah three instances one man came up
to me
called me a russian prostitute he was
their pimp though there was a bunch
around
and he thought that i was one of them i
wasn't another instance this woman came
up to me she goes
you smell like weed and i go really and
she goes you've been smoking oh no
this last one was quite rude
i was in the bathroom washing my hands
and minding my own business
and this young mom comes in with her
daughter who is about
eight or nine years old and the mom is a
little bit tipsy and she's like oh my
god like you're so beautiful this is not
like oh thank you thank you
uh i leave and she stops me and she goes
do you have a tick tock and i go yeah
yeah i do and she goes oh my god
sweetheart
show this girl your tick tock and so the
little girl starts showing me her tech
talking like okay cool and she goes you
should make one right now with her
what and i go huh she goes no like right
now i'll go make one
with my daughter you don't want to go i
actually have to get back to you because
no you don't
you don't want to make one with my
daughter and started seriously i swear i
started to get
more and more aggressive so i'm not
kidding you i'm in the bathroom for five
minutes doing
renegade no way i did it and i
you know i told my dad about it and he
goes
what the [ __ ] sistine like can't you say
no to people you can say no
i can't i don't know why i have you have
a weird problem with feeling
very guilty if you don't do something
for someone and in my brain
i go if you don't feel like doing it
don't do it
if you don't like them don't hang out
with them
you should have just said no i feel like
that was so inappropriate on her
i just feel scared of the confrontation
it makes me uncomfortable to say no to
people because i'd rather i think we
were also raised
yeah i know we also were told our mom
made us always um
make sure that we're making everyone
happy and we're being on our best
behavior
putting people first and um i think i've
had to learn how to balance that because
i think there's a good happy medium
between
pleasing someone but also someone
aggressively yelling at you to do a tick
tock with their
two-year-old daughter i really want to
see it though you should find it
she's probably tagged you but it's it
was bad how do you say no to people
i still just cannot figure you just say
uh right now i don't feel like it sorry
i did
and she kept coming back you say ma'am
[Laughter]
your way out of the bathroom in other
news i've so see i have more updates for
you what are those
something really funny i thought i
should just share happened to me the
other day we could cut this out
i don't care um
i was again another lonely night for me
i decided to you know pamper myself i
had a face mask on
i had my hair in rollers awesome i had a
robe on
i was in a rocking chair just eating
dinner looking at the sunset i'm
thinking this is the life you're outside
i don't
spoil myself give myself a little
pampering day
i'm outside and our dogs
have such a fascination with catching
lizards
they're obsessed with these days you
guys they are a fiend
they're like little lizard hunters
they're obsessed so
i always see them running around the
grass they can hardly catch one because
they're
coppa poos but um
as i'm sitting there rocking back and
forth i noticed that
billy are the youngest one or a littlest
one
caught a lizard in her mouth it was so
disgusting the tail is
swinging out of her mouth yeah oh it
gets better i pick up
uh billy and i start shaking her like
drop the lens
i'm shaking the dog she drops it buster
our other one
picks it up he has it in his mouth so
then i'm
shaking him and as this is all happening
right i look crazy first of all
rollers face mask robe shaking a dog
with a lizard in his mouth
we get a lot of tour boats that come by
yeah we do um and they always stop
knowing that it's sylvester stallone's
house
yeah and as i'm doing all of this a boat
comes by they stop
they're all screaming and waving and
laughing i'm assuming
but a whole boat of people see me doing
this then
the dogs chomp down a little too hard on
the lizard i managed to pull the lizard
out with my hands
i'm covered in lizard blood
that just reminded me of the time a
couple months ago a month ago where
sistine saw
um what's it called a mosquito on my
forehead and i didn't know
you guys this is actually kind of funny
wait so speaking of blood
um so sistine and i were in the car
we're about to go
uh go do a double date and um we're
looking cute
and steven looks at me let's just prep
us we're going golfing we're going
golfing and
sophie and i go golf clothes are not
cute
skirts aren't charged or short enough so
we go to amazon and we
get private skirts tiny tennis skirt and
the tightest little
children but i should have let us on the
course i know so um
we're in the car and sistine looks at me
and she goes sofia
don't move and i go what what and she
goes
i sleep backs me straight in the
forehead
and sofia instantly goes what the [ __ ] i
was like what the [ __ ]
what are you eating me in the face where
she goes there was a giant mosquito
and i wipe my hand on my forehead i look
at my hand
of blood i started
gagging i bolted out the car i was
even just worried of having a giant
freaking bump on my forehead
so gnarly it was so gnarly so you had
lizard blood and i had
mosquito blood or probably not even
mosquito bites plus someone else's
blood that was definitely an
embarrassing moment of my life um
a bunch of people witnessing that me
covered in lizard blood
i just scrubbed myself from them and it
was bad it was bad
you know what i'm super stoked about
what that
we got offered because you're gonna say
yeah this is one of our favorite shows
actually i think it is my favorite show
love island you guys sistine and i
we're offered you guys this is the
chance to go on the show
season that we've been asked to come on
usa
love island i don't know if i'm allowed
to say where it's taking place
but i know the details wait but can i
just say
it would be a dream to be a part of it
and i would be lying if i didn't ask mom
do you think this would be the worst
idea ever and she goes yeah
probably but you know what we i do think
that there is a point taken about
i don't even know why i just said it
like that love island us
is nowhere comparable to love island uk
and anyone that doesn't watch the show
absolutely watch it yes
you see it's 50 episodes but i'm telling
you right now you fly by though
so i fall in love i get this email and i
told sophie about it and she goes okay
dude i got the same one
my brain started thinking not such a bad
idea we get this email from one of the
producers of the show and he goes
you would be fabulous we'd love to have
you please come on
and instantly i go i
would not win but i would be a fan
favorite
you think so a hundred percent look at
maura higgins look at
molly mae if you guys don't know what
i'm talking about uk
but they didn't win their season but
they were so
likable that they didn't even need to
win and they're doing much better than
the yeah one
if we were in the uk season if uk came
up to us and was like
come on the show i'd be like yes but u.s
i have a strategy of one yeah how would
you
win i think we have different ones if i
wanted to win
if i wanted to win i just wouldn't be
crazy because i feel like all the crazy
girls uh
always just bite themself in the ass but
i would want to be a fan favorite i'd be
that girl that
wouldn't end up finding a match the
entire time
but ended up surviving the entire time
because either the people voted me to
stay
or i just got matched with a guy friend
so i would strategically just be
that you know supporting girl of all the
other couples just be the funny one
chilling eating okay i feel like i'm so
opposite so you go for one well no i i
yes you go for love if you're not first
i'm going if you're not first
or last if you're not first or last so i
go in like this
i pair up with the first guy that has
interest in me i'm gonna keep it going
as hard as i can and maybe he's gonna
flutter around
but i've watched the show enough that
you always talk to your girls before
if you're interested in their man you
always give them that respect
yeah girl code always girl code yeah you
don't get mugged off
by a guy you always go straight to the
sauce right
and you just tell them how you feel do
you say sauce or sauce sauce
the sauce sauce the secret sauce to the
sauce
there's no worse accent than sophie i
don't think i have that
bad of an accent but i would say ooh
i would love that i got a little the
celsius alcohol deliveries
you can't pass me the other one do you
want that flavor
yeah i like this one
[Music]
we got little if you're 21 and over and
you hear the words unwaxed
take a sip every time you hear
us say mugged off take a sip but no
genuinely my favorite show i just think
that the whole point is being
straightforward
telling everyone how you feel being as
honest as you can i already have a good
combination well i have a question
molly would you go
so you're playing it strategically not
really looking for love
but trying to trick the people into
thinking you found yes
the love so you'd win yeah you're not
going for love well yeah no by the way
does anyone go in that show for tr true
like genuine love like you know
no they're going in for the sistine you
literally just said you'd be the fan
favorite
you would be going in not i don't want
to go in there leaving with anyone
i think that would be the best if you
just left with yourself but you also
left
a winner that's kind of cool you leave
not kidding with anyone but probably
getting with someone from past seasons
exactly what i would do that's exactly
what i would do
um so yeah let us know if you guys think
we should be on love island
or how about this love island bring us
on the show but don't record it we'll
just do the show
if we wouldn't as a system just give us
the tape can you imagine the sisters
it would be disgustingly amazing it'd be
really good it would be real because we
don't have the same type
um so you guys know that scarlett came
on
last week's episode and everyone kept
saying make scarlett a regular
i mean if you want do you want us to no
fine by me i think we'll have her on
next week um and there was an
announcement that i'm sure she'll want
to tell you but
we're just too proud to to not share it
ourselves we're so proud of her
scarlett just got into her top pick of
college
yay scarlet round of applause it's such
an exciting time in a young person's
life
getting that acceptance that validation
it's really cool it's huge and you know
it's hard work like you just remember
high school and how many times you were
stressed out and oh my god
try to study for a test and then you're
trying to balance the social life and
then sports and
and then you get to that final lap and
you get into the school that you wanted
to get into or
you tried to and she's worked really
hard and she's one of those people
that's talked about college
her entire and she especially got into a
program
for acting and it was a really tough
program to get into and she's been
obsessed with acting since she was
younger it's coming full circle and i'm
excited it's really strange to see um
someone that you always looked at as
your baby sister become an adult
you know yeah turning 19. i know even
guys that are my age are starting to hit
on her and it's just
weird yeah
i mean she's she's growing up she's
growing up
oh i know baby scar
moving on to bigger and better things
and it makes me think about i
graduated over two years ago or wait
two years ago i don't know that's weird
i graduated a while
i got into college 2015 and it's 20 21.
are you kidding how does that make you
feel
well all right the fact that i'm turning
25
is this year is i you know i didn't
think i think that was that weird but
now it's actually sounding really weird
you know someone i was talking to a
girlfriend the other day
and she said that um once you turn
even at the age i'm so young i'm 22 and
you're so young too but
we're sort of approaching that age where
okay now you kind of have to start
planning for the rest of your life
even though it maybe it's different for
men and women but at least
for me and and the position that i want
to see myself later on down the line
once you hit the 26-27 mark it's like
okay
now you got to start looking for a life
partner you have three years to do that
then you have x amount of years to
you know get engaged and then get
married and then have babies because
there's a small one
there's so much pressure because i think
that for me like since i'm wearing 25
i have this whole pressure of like okay
i have to balance work and i have to
probably find my guy and so we're gonna
be together for a couple years then
we'll have kids and we're gonna get
married and
now coming to this point of being 25 my
mindset is so
not there at all and it's not saying
that i don't think that could happen but
i'm also
it gave me so much stress for i feel
like i'm having a quarter life crisis a
little bit
really a little bit what was your
expectation
graduating college coming out of college
what did you expect
you know your life to look like right
after that well you know you go into
college assuming and maybe you're in a
career
like in a major where it takes you to
the next step of your career
but i always do my career be so fluid
and
really not kind of set in one way and
our family is kind of like that too and
so i thought maybe out of college i'd
have everything figured out and just
because we have this podcast doesn't
mean like either sistine and i have
anything figured out we're just going it
but day by day we have ideas
you guys we are faking we're all about
faking it
this isn't even our wall this isn't even
our set
anyway but no but i i definitely think
that once i got up i would have had like
a boyfriend and maybe get married in a
couple years and all this stuff and
and have a full-blown nine-to-five
career or a
steady inflow of cash coming in yeah and
at first it gave me i was having of
worry and i was freaked out but
i just think that just don't put
pressure on yourself i think
i say that but we still do we still
still do we still do but i think we're
getting better with it
and i think if anyone is in their 20s
and they feel this way
don't put pressure on it your path is
your path
my path is my path like you may feel
behind but you're it's not you're behind
you're just
in your own route i don't know i feel as
if it's going to be one of those
situations where
someone who is much older than you and
wiser than you
always says you know don't rush your 20s
you have your whole life to figure it
out
and et cetera et cetera but once you're
in your 20s we're in the thick of it
you always blow it off and say no i
should have it figured out i should have
this and then we're going to get to that
person's age and say
[ __ ] why did i put two well you're only
22. how do you
feel like you're gonna be when you're 25
the thing is i've always had such a goal
in mind of what i want to be
and what i want to do with my life and i
don't know even in class i always sat
there thinking
there is not a universe in which i'm not
going to allow this to happen for me
so i guess subconsciously i'm just
manifesting what i've wanted for so long
and you know we really sort of have met
the main characters of our
careers i think we did these past few
months and
i think starting now before i felt
lost as hell i didn't know what i wanted
to do i was modeling and then i quit
that and then i was acting
and then that's all you know all over
the place so i really didn't know what i
want to do but now i sort of feel like
okay i've tried everything that i
thought i wanted
that didn't make me happy doing what
we're doing now which
we can't really talk about but we will
very soon
and i think a good i a good indicator or
like a good example is
really looking at christina and i
because she was in this kind of
career a bit longer than i was like i
thought that's all i wanted like she's
been in this kind of more social
not social media but i'd say
i guess entertainment career yeah
she's been modeling she's acted she's
been on social media
longer really than i've been on it and
it just shows you like
we're both in the same position and i
went to college for four years and
it doesn't mean anything different like
so you end up sometimes at the same
place no matter if you feel behind or
not and
just because she's younger and is in the
same position i'm 25 i don't look at her
and go like oh [ __ ] like i'm
behind yeah i look at her and i go okay
cool we're doing this together now and
this was all supposed to happen
yeah you know totally and so i i did
have a quarter life crisis and i'm still
in this mindset where i still want to
have fun in my 20s
and i am still trying to have fun in my
20s i think the takeaway is
have fun in your 20s yeah you know don't
put that
unnecessary pressure on yourself but
also
look at a future look at a starting
point that you want to reach by a
certain time and i think that's
important as well because if you have
something to work for and look forward
to it honestly makes the the grind to
get there much better yeah and that's
what i'm doing right now i have a plan
i'm like okay five years this is gonna
happen for me
and if you see that for yourself it's
going to happen
and i also think go into everything i
feel like i might since in my 20s
we've really tried every single thing
we're not we don't hide from it i think
just
go for it because yeah don't by the way
do you how many people said that this
podcast
would have been dude we got a lot of
guys we got laughed at people
oh you're not gonna do that we got
laughed at by people that should have
been our biggest
i know and look at us now people
there are things coming that you don't
know what
is gonna i don't really know how to end
that
you don't know what guys stop coming
it's gonna knock your socks off man
those socks are flying across the line
across the room but yeah
um so quarter life crisis was coming i
think i
might be crying on my birthday when i'm
25. maybe i'll cry on my 30s
who knows or maybe i'll have the best
time we'll see man i'm gonna throw you
such a
dirty thirty i can't
wait i can't wait we were talking about
our bachelorette parties and how
dirty they're gonna be oh
this is what we were saying so we were
talking about
our bachelorette parties and i think
you're supposed to have one
bachelorette no right one maid of honor
yeah i see i don't even know i was like
one bachelorette
you're supposed to have one maid of
honor for the bride right but yeah
sophia squirrel and i were saying okay
we can't pick one because
no offense scarlett neither one of us
want you to be ours
because no you'll be great but just
extremely unorganized scarlett's just
you know what she's going to be the
creative mind to get all the
the crazy aspects of everything will be
because she can't
figure out a schedule or a planner or a
calendar to save her life
but scarlett brings the good time sophia
brings the organization
and i bring a little bit of the razzle
dazzle something that you just won't
expect maybe we should curveball you be
the maid of honor of your own wedding
too just the three of us playing
everything
so we were saying that you know sophia's
wedding when scarlet and i plan your
bachelorette party
it's almost like one crazy person me
planning it and then an even crazier
person tasmanian devil scarlet
planning it good luck with that i know
my i already know
my whoever is going to marry me don't
ask about my bachelorette party
it's just gonna be one of those things
like what happens in vegas stays in
vegas
exactly scarlett said there's no way
you're not cheating on your fiance
mine is gonna be sorry future fiance oh
well oh well
so as promised we are going to do
another story time segment but i was
thinking you know since this is new
we're playing around with the name a
little bit sophia what do you think of
calling this segment
bedtime stories oh so we could put our
little unwaxers to bed
you know we tucked them in read them a
little goodnight story
what do you guys think of that bedtime
stories should we call it that yeah
that's called bedtime stuff all right
this is the bedtime stories
segment sistine brought in a great one
last week
about how i humiliated myself in front
of her ex and now i'm gonna share
another one
of me humiliating myself in front of a
guy okay
so this is the story
of the post
kiss craze i don't even know i can't
think of a title right now
okay it's my first week of college and
we are in
these dorm rooms that are co-ed and this
is the co-ed dorm that
everyone wants to go in college because
even though it's the oldest building has
no ac
really smelly usually when one kid gets
six and second there everyone gets sick
that's how
on top of each other everyone is yeah
there's no ventilation there's no
ventilation
there's no space but it is so much fun
because
everyone is a freshman everyone's new
and everyone kind of gets together
so as i said before it's coed and down
the hall
there is this kid that still today is
one of the nicest people i've ever met
and he was always a good friend of mine
throughout college
so what i'm about to explain i promise
you if he ever listens to this i
swear and he probably would remember
this i there's no hard feelings and
you're still the best person but what
are you here guys to say
so i remember i thought he was cute and
this was like the first week of school
and i was like you know like i'm gonna
call him john lee john so sweet john's
like
very nice to me why don't i just keep
hanging out with him and so we love john
john is just the sweetest little nugget
um
stop no here goes he is a nugget but uh
so i remember one night
we come back from a party and we
go in front of his dorm room and
it's in that moment like i'm about to
have my first kiss in college like
woohoo
i thought you're gonna say your first
kiss period no college sweet which is
like not a big deal but i just remember
it was
i was so nervous i'm like i only had one
boyfriend in high school yeah and
i felt like rebellious i was like oh
we're gonna kiss before anything
get it girl i was naive you guys i was
naive
but i remember we go in and we start
kissing
and it was the worst kiss i've ever had
in my life
and here in this moment this is what i'm
thinking in my head it was
what made it so bad it was just the lips
were really
tense and it was sloppy and teeth teeth
yeah it was
genuinely like horrible horrible
cannibal
it was so bad i made it might have been
bad too i don't know
are you eating his face i know it was
bull i don't know what it was but it was
just so
bad and in this moment i remember this
thought i go
fight or flight fight or flight fight or
flight fight what is the fight i'm
questioning i don't know what it what i
don't know what was i fighting
what are you gonna fight and i'll say it
through the pain i hear flight flight
flight flight
i instead anything push him off me
and dart down the hallway
and get um run into the stairwell and
the door closes
and now i'm stuck in the stairwell and
i'm out on the outside part of the
stairwell
let me just hold on slow down so you
push this guy off so we're kissing and
let me recap
this you're talking so fast all right
you've pushed this guy off of you you
run down the hallway you lock yourself
in a stairwell
yeah well i just i go to the stairwell
because i think flight i got to get out
of this situation of course
instead of just pulling away and being
like goodnight
i run away run i'm 18 years old
this goes back to that conversation we
just had about
saying no when you don't want like
something yeah wait so
now i'm in the stairwell okay and i'm on
this outside part of it where it's not
really where the kids
it's i think it's an emergency stairwell
of course so
i turned towards throne like [ __ ] how am
i gonna get inside
and it says if you open this door an
alarm will go off
so i'm stuck and i don't have my phone
oh sofia
sistine oh no here it goes i'm sitting
there i'm going
downstairs trying to look for anybody
i'm looking for like a fire escape
there's nothing i'm sitting there for 30
minutes
eventually it's the scene here goes it
gets worse i look through the window
and i see him down the hallway and i
knock on it going
can you help me and the kid that i
pushed off me
had to come save me from the stairwell
and i had to awkwardly
walk back with him pass to
drop him off at his dorm room and walk
to mine
and that was my first college kiss
oh no sistine it kind of reminds me of
my first kiss story
what was yours well you had to run away
and you hid in a stairwell i scaled the
side of a house to get away
what okay here's another cesine what's
your bedroom
really quick it was my first kiss ever
um i'm still friends with this person
today
and we always make a joke because it was
such a bad first kiss that we have to
redeem ourselves
but he's a girlfriend so it was just
never we can't can't do that you're like
we can't
win no no we cannot um and
anyway it was like always it was we
always talked about it was gonna happen
it was gonna happen
and and um i think i was 16
and i we start hooking up i have
no idea what i'm doing clearly he
doesn't either because
again it was a cannibal situation he was
like eating my face and it was painful
and there's this ongoing joke like who
bit who
it could have been both of us it was so
bad right
he goes i'll be right back leaves for
two seconds we're in the backyard
my friends are on the balcony
when i look up that was right above us
and they were like woo woo yes
get it and i was so embarrassed i go
looked at my best friend and go
[ __ ] help me help me i gotta get out of
here
she and her friend uh pull their arms
down
they lift me i i'm not kidding you it
was a two-story thing i got up to the
second story we ran
on the roof of the house what ran down
the other side of the roof of the house
jumped off the other side of the house
and uh ran on the street and
what is wrong with that and he came back
and he goes
what the hell yeah wait what what was
wrong with us why i don't know
i mean at least you were 16 i was in
college and i ran away from my make out
yeah but honestly now that i think about
it remember that character from split
how he can just like scale things very
easily like spider-man
i don't know i got some superhuman power
fight or flight baby fighter flight i
flew
i was like whoa where did i get the
ability to jump so high and like
my fingers got sticky like spiderman
thank god
those two guys are nice people because
i'm just glad he didn't tell anybody but
maybe he didn't want to tell anybody
because that's really embarrassing a
girl ran away
yeah i we didn't talk for a good six to
eight months
because that might but that's my story
time um if you ever have a bad kiss
just don't run there we go that's it
wait don't i have a good idea run away
if any of the listeners
have any good bedtime stories that we
should share
oh on the show please write them in they
can be anonymous or not if you want
and we'll share them i think that would
be so fun yeah any horrible
funny it could be about scary anything
making me sad
because we we are we are open to all i
love crying
i i do love actually i don't like crying
you guys this is right
this is a fun idea let's do it write
some in so guys write some in
and send it to our instagram we'll read
it in our dms
our but my bedtime story and
we are back with another conspiracy
theory
and i'm bringing it this time finally
i know i bring in all the conspiracy
that's not true
yes i do and i would also like to point
out i never get the response that i
think i deserve from you
yeah so because yours are i'm gonna be a
tough cookie today
okay so i feel like this conspiracy
theory
everyone's had heard about and i love
this one yes
love this one because i'm all about
these kind of meta
type situations and it is
a simulation theory are we living
in a computer simulation i wanted to do
this one
are you a sim oh that's meta man
am i a sim are you a sim
chances are they say it's 50 50
which is kind of crazy wait there's a 50
chance that someone
a higher being is currently controlling
you no yeah of course
of course if that's the case not too bad
not too bad not mad not mad about it
thank you um but first you have to ask
the question what is reality and
so firstly we have to answer the
question what is reality
and reality is anything we perceive as
using one or more of the five senses
taste smell touch hearing and sight
but some out of the box thinkers
theorize that reality is merely
an ultra high-tech computer simulation
in which
we sim live sim work sim laugh
sim love that everything that we do in
life is them sex
[Music]
sim get trunks same get blackout
sim podcast skill of buildings
sin bad kiss oh god so the question is
if we live
in a simulated universe has been very
much debated since the enlightenment
period so a lot
of people from even back then assumed
that we were living in
a simulation period and one of the
forward thinkers i think
elon musk is one of the bigger guys that
has
said definitely oh yeah he has said
that we are living in simulation i was i
read something that he said there's a
99.999
chance that we are well so it this is a
question
do you ever experience this can't be
real
sometimes or deja vu
deja vu for sure that some glitches
happen like in the matrix like a
ghost maybe the ghost well we hear as
always
uh simulation glitch i always look up
um on youtube there's a compilation of
all these simulation
glitches with basketball players doing
the exact same
like six of them doing the same footing
a bird flapping in place and not moving
anywhere
stuff like that yeah i believe it's hard
for me
i get so 50 50. so they think there's
there's no real proof
of it but there's one of three scenarios
that this guy named
nick bostrom wrote so i think this is
actually kind of interesting
one that all human-like civilizations in
the universe will go extinct before they
develop
the technological capacity to create
these realities which is like
we have a ceiling to our advancement and
either
climate change or um
robots self-replicating and taking over
the universe before we can actually get
to that point
i believe that's gonna which i think is
probably what i think is gonna happen so
two
if any simulations i mean if any
civilizations get to this point
where we can do it that we
will do it because it's unethical
that we have the technology to become
or create a sim life but we won't do it
because
it's just okay right we have maybe this
is a stupid question
if we have the technology to become a
sim life
but you said that there's a 50 chance we
already are right so this is the thing
or three advanced civilizations would
have the ability to create many many
simulations
and that means there are far more
simulated worlds than non-simulated ones
so it's more saying that in the best way
i can explain it because it i was
reading about it and i got
really deep in this rabbit hole um
that there we already have gotten to
that point
and we're just a simulated world do you
see what i'm saying
that we're not just the primary
i know why do they make my hands so big
yeah that's my first question why do
they keep cutting this why did they give
me keratosis
on my arms hold on why didn't i get a
bigger butt
okay here's my question who
is controlling this system so that
that's the whole thing
i mean it questions religion and
questions that
i mean alien everything it could be
aliens what is your takeaway that we all
my takeaway
is that the fact that okay
i just think that if we are living in a
simulated world and i played sims 4
and 3 when i was growing up i just think
that's kind of insane if that is
the case and we are doing what sims is
doing
maybe the um how did someone think of
creating sims
then obviously the people that are
creating us are trying to give us a
message
saying that we are being controlled like
the sims because they're so realistic
oh god okay well let me know if you guys
believe we're in a simulation because
kind of i do a little bit
just a little bit
i just think life is more fun when you
believe in all these conspiracy theories
i agree and i definitely believe in
lizard people and
the christmas conspiracy the lizard
people is totally real the christmas
conspiracy is definitely not real i
believe in the spongebob one
oh you do yeah okay she said that
spongebob is on uh
meth he's on methamphetamine yeah and
patrick sorry is just smoking that
you guys yes obviously we need help with
these theories
so please write some in uh let's
transition
to our favorite segment the unsolicited
advice segment
and just a reminder since you love our
reminders
you guys can submit your questions on
the apple podcast page give us that five
star
give us a nice review we love your
reviews and write your question
in the review section that is the only
place we will answer it
and for those of you doing it correctly
you get a gold star baby
thank you so this person said i can
honestly say
you know what this person wrote a really
nice compliment about the podcast i
could choose not to read it
but i want to inflate our egos a little
bit so i'm going gonna read what they
said
i can honestly say this is the only
podcast i listen to and enjoy
every minute of it i've watched every
episode on youtube even after listening
to them on apple podcast
you can say i'm obsessed you put so much
effort and love into your podcast which
is why
your podcast is my favorite thank you so
much
because you know what that's true i
don't think people realize we actually
love this podcast and we put so much
effort into it
so that is just such a nice it's nice
thank you so much thank you
this person wrote i constantly overthink
and think everyone hates me for no
reason so my question is
how do you stay confident and my advice
on how to stop
overthinking these are both things i
think we've touched on
confidence and overthinking we've
definitely touched on them in the past
but
i can certainly relate to you when you
say that you think
everyone hates you um because i
definitely went through a phase of
thinking nobody liked me
i thought my friends always secretly
didn't want to be my friend and we're
just doing it
at a convenience or whatever it was so i
totally understand where you're coming
from but you also have to understand
that is just
a frame of mind and i realized it was an
insecurity on my part
and i stopped blaming other people for
that
yeah i think it can just get uh
into a whirlwind of just
self-doubt and you can just get really
caught up in believing your own
yeah your own beliefs and it could be
just
fake things you know it is just your own
insecurity talking to its own
insecurities
you need to stop and realize that you
are a special person there is no one
like you no one can
ever do or say or have the same
experiences as you so you have to own
that
and say and wear it with pride like you
are special
and if they don't like you for whatever
reason they don't like you for that
reason
and by the way i overthink i've always
had a problem overthinking any situation
any relationship any friendship and i've
had to really i mean i think sistine's
kind of my filter to help me out and i
got lucky on that
but at the end of the day it's really
nothing is a big deal
when it comes to that stuff like no
one's honestly thinking about you as
intensely as you're thinking about you
i know for me i'm always at what if what
if what if what if and
what i always tell sophia when she's
really overthinking something is
will this matter in a week's time will
you think about it this much in a week's
time and if she says yes
then we'll actually go through it and
pick it apart and i think when it comes
to also going out and how to stay
confident
i always like to say wear do
or be something that makes you feel your
best and you know maybe you have a
certain outfit that
makes you feel the most confident or you
have a certain routine that throughout
the day just makes you feel
better whether it's working out going on
a walk and i think
doing one thing a day that just makes
you feel better about yourself
does totally emphasize
your confidence and make you feel better
i also think confidence comes with age
and time
and i just recently learned how to
sort of own my [ __ ] and own who i am by
pretending to be confident even when i
always
wasn't confident it sounds so cliche but
faking it till you make it
actually trains your brain to start
doing it all the time and then you're
going to
just be confident naturally and you're
not alone
we all overthink we all have our days of
self-doubt and we all assume
things that people don't like us for and
just remember
they're not and you just be you and
own it because at the end of the day you
have one life and it's not worth it
and it's wasting it on people that don't
like you and if you think
people don't like you just remember
they're thinking about themselves always
they're not thinking about you so if you
just remember that
get it out of your head own your [ __ ]
wear your confidence with pride stop
overthinking and drink a freaking
seltzer
you know if you have overthinking
problems just write it out and go
does this really look like that's
happening all of those thoughts
look at the page no it's not so just
move on scrunch that paper up
throw it into the fire pit if you have a
fire pit near you
or just in the trash and move on it's
not worth it
i hope that helped yeah you know what's
funny with our advice sometimes we go
very soft in the beginning
and at the end we get super aggressive
like get that out of your head
well because that's how we work because
normally when we approach our own
insecurities and our
our own overthinking i think we go a
little soft and then instantly we go
like
get over it you're a bad [ __ ] you're a
bad [ __ ] you can walk you can talk you
look great
i'm a bad [ __ ] you can't kill me that's
a um
vine i think that's a vine if you are
still in that generation i know this was
a
a lot more chaotic and uh i think it was
fun though i love these i
love me too we have a lot of funny
stories i think and i did not even know
about the kiss
when you skilled the wall so i learned
about that and your
lizard blood experience you know what
sofia i missed you i'm happy you're back
with me
happy to be back in this meeting too
thank you guys so much for listening
and supporting and writing into the
podcast every single week we read them
it means the world to us so and if
there's any segments or topics that you
really like us talking about please let
us know we love your advice we
want to hear feedback because i mean our
mom can tell us so much
so you tell us yeah
we're done jen i'm just kidding no we'll
we will be back next tuesday
and we will see you soon bye